This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。百分之二百。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中，关于心理坚韧度、体能以及培养复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你终将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。节目名称中的“2”是数字的2。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他将罪有应得。我们常说，相信你的好闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《回顾当年》播客。对1979年来说，那对我是一个重大的时刻。84年对我意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是个疯狂的年份。那是个疯狂的年份。我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回顾当年》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的法则》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《艰难成长的法则》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控使人怀上双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are talking about decision making, but not in a way that you expect. We're not talking about how we can make decisions, how we know that we're making the right decision. We're not going to talk about how to weigh up costs and benefits, how to have
后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《受困之爱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一档探讨我们二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化与转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十岁的心理。今天，我们讨论的是决策制定，但并不是以你意料之中的方式。我们不是在谈论我们如何做出决策，我们如何知道自己做出了正确的决定。我们不会讨论如何权衡成本与收益，如何在决策中拥有
certainty in your decisions. We're actually going to talk about the aftermath of making a choice, where you realize, hey, this actually isn't right for me. This actually isn't what I believe in. This actually isn't what I want for my life. And why it feels. feels so hard in those moments to admit that we were wrong or, I guess, to change our mind. I obviously on this podcast reflects so much on my own personal growth. If you've been here for a long time, you will know that I started the psychology of your 20s basically as a way to kind of therapeutize myself and to kind of like interrogate, explore, research, like the stuff that was going on in my own life and in my 20s.
确定性。我们实际上要讨论的是做出选择后的余波，那时你意识到，嘿，这其实并不适合我。这其实并不是我所信仰的。这其实不是我想要的生活。以及为什么在那些时刻，承认我们错了，或者说改变我们的主意，会让人感觉如此艰难。我显然在这个播客中反思了许多关于我个人成长的内容。如果你在这里听了很久，你就会知道我创办《你二十岁的心理学》基本上是为了自我治疗的一种方式，去审视、探索、研究那些发生在我自己生活以及二十岁时的事情。
And a big thing that I am learning right now is exactly this. Changing your mind and having to tell people that or having to let people down is incredibly uncomfortable. It is also absolutely necessary, especially in this decade. And I have had to do this a lot recently. I had to turn down like a really big business opportunity that I really wanted to do, but realize, like, you know, no, I'm not right for this or it's not the right time for me. I've changed my mind on some of my political opinions recently.
而我现在正在学习的一个重大内容正是如此。改变你的想法，不得不告诉别人这一点，或者不得不让人失望，是极其不舒服的。这也是绝对必要的，尤其是在这个十年里。我最近不得不做很多这样的事情。我不得不拒绝一个非常大的商业机会，那个机会我真的很想做，但后来意识到，你知道，不，我并不适合这个，或者这对我来说不是合适的时间。我最近改变了我的一些政治观点。
But what really inspired me to talk about this and what has made me realize why we need to talk about this more was a friend of mine who recently called off an engagement and she's given me permission to talk about this. But basically she knew when she said yes to her now ex-fiancee, like in the bottom of her heart that this wasn't right. And she ignored it for months. They'd been together for four years. Her whole family loved him. Everyone said they were soulmates. But the relationship obviously looked very different from within, which, you know, as a friend, you only really find out later on most of the time.
但真正启发我谈论这个话题，并让我意识到为什么我们需要更多地讨论它的，是我的一位朋友，她最近取消了订婚，她允许我谈论这件事。但基本上，当她对她现在的前未婚夫说“我愿意”时，她内心深处就知道这是不对的。她忽视了几个月。他们已经在一起四年了。她的整个家人都很喜欢他。每个人都说他们是灵魂伴侣。但从内部来看，这段关系显然非常不同，你知道的，作为一个朋友，大多数时候你只有在事后才会真正发现。
And she was telling me in hindsight how she was going back and forth, kind of plagued with guilt, plagued with doubt, plagued with this fear of disappointing people, people who would kind of come to expect something from her in any way, something from her relationship. and finally she just had to make the call. Obviously, in the aftermath, we've been talking a lot about not like how this happened, but yeah, how did this happen? How was it that she ended up engaged to someone who she knew wasn't right for her? And we've been talking a lot about this whole concept of having to admit to ourselves
她跟我讲了事后回想时，她是多么地摇摆不定，饱受内疚、怀疑的折磨，饱受这种害怕让人失望的恐惧的折磨，那些对她有所期待的人，无论如何对她的生活有所期待，对她的关系有所期待。最终她只能做出决定。显然，在事后，我们一直在讨论的不是这事是怎么发生的，而是，是的，这到底是怎么发生的？为什么她最终会和一个她明知不适合自己的人订婚？我们一直在讨论这个概念，即不得不向自己承认
and having to admit to others that we have changed as a person, that we have changed our minds and how if we talked about how truly normal this is, we would be saving people, a lot of doubt, a lot of heartbreak, and a lot of kind of wasted time at the end of the day, if time can never be wasted, but that's another discussion. So to get into it, this is a quick summary of what we are going to discuss. First, I want to talk about why we resist changing our minds because of a fear of being judged, a fear of disappointing people, especially our parents. We're going to talk about sunk cost fallacy and what it actually means and what it feels like and what comes after disappointment.
并且不得不向他人承认，我们作为一个人的改变，我们改变了主意，如果我们谈论这到底有多么正常，我们将为人们省去许多怀疑、许多心碎，以及归根结底许多浪费的时间——如果时间永远不会被浪费的话，但那是另一个讨论了。所以为了切入正题，这是我们将要讨论内容的简要总结。首先，我想谈谈为什么我们由于害怕被评判、害怕让人失望（尤其是我们的父母）而抗拒改变主意。我们将讨论沉没成本谬误及其真正含义、真实感受，以及失望之后会发生什么。
Secondly, we're going to talk about the cost of staying loyal to old and outdated versions of ourselves and why actually being less afraid to say, I was wrong, I made the wrong decision, this is not right for me, would actually counterintuitively allow us to make decisions easier and with a lot less anxiety. It's a big topic, guys, but honestly, I think there's a lot. a lot of clarity that comes with accepting this huge truth. You can't always make the right decision, but you cannot make a better one unless you have the courage to admit I was wrong. And so hopefully this episode gives you the courage without further ado. Let's get into
其次，我们将讨论忠于旧的、过时的自己所付出的代价，以及为什么实际上不那么害怕去说“我错了，我做出了错误的决定，这不适合我”，反而会以一种反直觉的方式让我们能够更轻松地做出决定，并减少许多焦虑。这是一个宏大的话题，伙计们，但老实说，我认为接受这个巨大的真相会带来极大的清晰度。你不可能总是做出正确的决定，但除非你有勇气承认“我错 了”，否则你无法做出更好的决定。所以希望这一期节目能给你勇气，废话不多说。让我们进入
why it is okay to change your mind. Stay with us. So I know I've kind of framed this discussion as changing your mind about big decisions, like an engagement or I don't know, job but honestly I think that this extends to just about anything changing your mind about your beliefs your political opinions um the kind of people you want to surround yourself with the kind of clothes you want to wear where you want to live who you want to be with what kind of person you see yourself as like there are countless moments and forks in the road where we make choices and we change our mind about who we want to be either consciously or unconsciously none of these things are ever set in stone just because they were once important to you or because you once claimed it
为什么改变主意是可以的。请继续收听。所以，我知道我把这次讨论设定为关于重大决策的改变主意，比如订婚，或者我不知道，工作，但老实说，我认为这延伸到几乎任何事情——改变你对信仰的想法、你的政治观点、你想和什么样的人在一起、你想穿什么样的衣服、你想住在哪里、你想成为什么样的人、你认为自己是什么样的人——有无数的时刻和十字路口，我们在那里做出选择，并在有意或无意中改变了我们想成为谁的想法。这些事情从来都不是一成不变的，仅仅因为它们曾经对你很重要，或者因为你曾经宣称它
was something that you believed in. You are allowed to change as a person. When you really interrogate this as well, oftentimes some of the core pillars of our identity that we feel most loyal to, some of our core opinions and beliefs, are things that we first started to believe in at like 18 or maybe even younger. It was often things that were influenced by family, influenced by the people around us, by our environments. And the influence of these factors kind of diminishes when we leave those spaces and the older we get. And we also importantly start to really independently rethink parts of our lives that we've kind of always just assumed or we've kind of just taken for granted or, you know, decisions that we just felt were inevitable
是你所信仰的东西。允许你作为一个当你真正审视这一点时，你会发现，往往构成我们身份核心支柱、我们最忠实的一些核心意见和信仰，其实是我们大约18岁甚至更年轻时开始相信的东西。这往往是受家庭、受周围人、受环境影响的东西。而当我们离开这些空间，年龄越来越大时，这些因素的影响力就会减弱。而且同样重要的是，我们开始真正独立地重新思考生活中那些我们一直以为是理所当然的，或者我们只是顺理成章接受的事情，或者，你知道的，那些我们仅仅觉得不可避免的决定，
because someone had wanted them from us. Someone had served it up on a silver platter and said, this is what we've chosen for you. Now, changing your mind about those things, terrifying, scary, also a good thing. This is what we call individuation. It is an essential part of our psychological development whereby we separate from the collective or the norms that have previously shaped us so that we can carve out our own unique persona and unique identity. It is one of our goals, one of our missions as humans, to go through this phase in our life. If you want to move from child to adult and then from adult to individual, you have to go through this period, maybe a couple of times.
因为有人曾对我们有所期待。有人把它放在银盘上端过来，说，这就是我们为你选择的。现在，改变你对这些事情的看法，虽然可怕、吓人，但也是一件好事。这就是我们所说的个性化（individuation）。这是我们心理发展中至关重要的一部分，通过它我们从集体或以前塑造过我们的规范中分离出来，以便我们能够塑造出自己独特的人格和独特的身份。这是我们的目标之一，作为人类的任务之一，就是在我们的生活中经历这个阶段。如果你想从儿童转变为成人，然后从成人转变为个体，你必须经历这个时期，也许要经历好几次。
And people who don't do this, I think we all know one of them. They end up basically without an identity, very miserable. And what this theory says is that they are incredibly malleable to others' opinions, others' expectations, and they go through life never really figuring out who they are. That sounds pretty scary to me. Now, this word, individuation, very serious, might sound like a very serious term, but you have probably, if you are in your 20s, already experienced this to a degree. Even if you're like 18 or younger, that's when this really begins to take hold.
而那些没有这样做的人，我想我们都认识其中一个。他们最终基本上没有个性，非常痛苦。而这个理论所说的是，他们对别人的意见、别人的期望极其顺从，他们过着一生，却从来没有真正弄清楚自己是谁。这听起来对我来说相当可怕。现在，这个词，个性化，非常严肃，可能听起来是一个非常严肃的术语，但如果你正处于二十多岁，你可能已经在某种程度上经历过这一点。即使你大约18岁或更年轻，这也是这个过程真正开始扎根的时候。
It's when we decide, you know, hey, maybe I don't want to study law at university. just because my parents expect me to. Maybe I don't fully believe my family's ultra-conservative viewpoints. Maybe I don't like dressing this way. Maybe this is more my personal style. We realize maybe I don't like being around these people. Maybe I don't like my hometown. Maybe I don't want to have kids.
这是当我们决定，你知道的，嘿，也许我不想在大学里学法律，仅仅因为我的父母对我有期望。也许我并不完全相信我家庭的超保守观点。也许我不喜欢这样穿衣打扮。也许这更符合我的个人风格。我们意识到，也许我不喜欢和这些人在一起。也许我不喜欢我的家乡。也许我不想生孩子。
Maybe I do want to have kids after saying that you thought one thing for a long time and maybe now you feel differently about those matters. Our 20s are a period where we change our mind a whole. whole lot. And we have a lot of these sort of what we would call epiphanies, these like come to moments where we're like, wait, what am I doing? Like, I don't like this. I don't believe this. I am not this. Firstly, it's because we gain a lot of independence physically but also emotionally. But secondly, we are undergoing rapid identity development and experimentation. You may find yourself wanting different things every three months, every year, every week maybe, that's actually
也许在经历了长时间认为一件事之后，你确实想要孩子，而现在你对这些事情有了不同的感觉。我们的二十岁是一个我们彻底改变主意的时期。我们有很多这样的，我们可以称之为顿悟的时刻，这些醍醐灌顶的时刻让我们觉得，等等，我在干什么？我不喜欢这样。我不相信这个。我不是这样的人。首先，这是因为我们在身体上以及情感上也获得了很大的独立性。但其次，我们正在经历快速的身份发展和实验。你可能会发现自己每三个月、每年、甚至每周都想要不同的东西，这其实
totally normal. You know, one day you might feel like, oh, I need to leave this city and never come back. I'm going to move to Puerto Rico. I'm going to move to London. And then the next, you're like, no, I'm going to find a really nice person and settle down, or I'm going to start a farm. And then the next you're thinking, I'm going to go back to university and I'm going to learn a trade. And it's like a freaking cyclone in your mind of possibilities. that's amazing. That's actually exactly where you should be. I don't know if anyone's ever told you this, but that is, you're doing it right. You may have heard this idea that our brains aren't fully developed until 25. I think that's a very famous, a famous fact that is actually a myth that is actually
完全正常。你知道，有一天你可能会觉得，哦，我需要离开这座城市，再也不回来。我要搬到波多黎各去。我要搬去伦敦。然后转眼间，你又觉得，不，我要找一个非常好的人安定下来，或者我要去开办一个农场。然后接下来你又在想，我要回到大学去学一门手艺。这就像你脑海中充满了可能性的龙卷风。这太棒了。这其实正是你应该处的状态。我不知道是否有人对你这么说过，但这就是——你做得很对。你可能听说过这种观点，即我们的大脑在25岁之前没有完全发育成熟。我认为这是一个非常著名的，一个著名的事实，但这实际上是一个神话，它实际上
not entirely true and there's actually no solid evidence for this. Our brains continue to develop across our lifespan, they actually peak in maturation anywhere between 20 to our early 30s. It's a very broad and individual process. I think the reason we hear 25 is because 25 just sounds like a fun number. So our brains aren't fully developed at 25, but this is a period where we are doing a lot of fine tuning, especially in the prefrontal cortex, which this place, this part of our brain, it governs planning, it governs decision making. it governs things like impulse control.
并不完全真实，而且实际上没有坚实的证据支持这一点。我们的大脑在我们的一生中都在继续发育，它们的成熟度实际上在20岁到30岁出头之间达到顶峰。这是一个非常广泛且因人而异的过程。我认为我们听到25岁的原因是因为25岁听起来像是一个有趣的数字。所以我们的大脑在25岁时并没有完全发育成熟，但这是一个我们正在进行大量微调的时期，特别是在前额叶皮层，这个地方，我们大脑的这一部分，它管辖着规划，它管辖着决策。它管辖着冲动控制之类的事情。
And so with this ongoing development, that means that our sense of judgment, our priorities, our long-term thinking is still under construction. It is still shifting constantly. And we also, just because of our age, have more doors open to us than we probably ever will. In our teen years, you know, we are kind of limited by our age. We're kind of limited by our maturity. As we get older, we also become limited. by past decisions that we made in our 20s, you know, the decision to have kids, the decision to
因此，随着这种持续的发展，这意味着我们的判断力、我们的优先级、我们的长期思考仍在建设中。它仍在不断变化。而且由于我们的年龄，我们面前打开的大门比我们可能想象的任何时候都要多。在我们的青少年时期，你知道的，我们某种程度上受到年龄的限制。我们某种程度上受到成熟度的限制。随着我们年龄的增长，我们也受到了限制。受到我们在二十岁时做出的过去决定的限制，你知道的，生孩子的决定，决定
settle down in a certain place, the decision to get a mortgage. So this is like the most perfect little space and like nugget of time where our choices are so abundant. We're young, we're hopefully healthy. And we're like a kid in a candy store rushing about being like, no I want this one like no I want this one I want this life I want this life we can't choose it's why we make plans for the future maybe like six months out and then like because we are changing so rapidly during this decade by the time we get there we've like already changed our minds again that doesn't mean you were lying about that choice or that that wasn't a priority at some stage it is literally just that the fact like our the rate at which we are changing as individuals outpaces the
在某个地方安定下来的决定，背上房贷的决定。所以这是一个最完美的小空间和时间的金矿，我们的选择是如此丰富。我们很年轻，希望也很健康。我们就像糖果店里的孩子一样跑来跑去，心里想着：不，我要这个——不，我要那个，我想要这种生活，我想要那种生活——我们无法抉择。这就是为什么我们为未来制定计划，也许大约六个月后，然后由于我们在这一十年中变化太快，等我们到达那个时间点时，我们就像已经再次改变了主意。这并不意味着你在那次选择上撒谎了，或者那在某个阶段不是首要任务。这实际上只是说明——我们作为个体变化的速率，有时超过了
rate at which we can sometimes make decisions and follow through on them. It is literally that you become a different person psychologically. I think in our 20s like every six months. And I think that's important. This is quite literally the definition of trial and error. And I've said it before. I will continue to say it. Life is not meant to be a recipe where step one naturally leads into step two and step
我们做出决定并将其贯彻到底的速率。这实际上意味着你在心理上变成了另一个人。我认为在我们的二十岁，就像每六个月一样。我认为这很重要。这字面意思就是“试错”的定义。我以前说过。我将继续说下去。生活绝不应该是一份食谱，其中第一步自然而然地通向第二步和第三
three until you've made the dish you decided on at the beginning. It is a series of experiments. and even the experiments that don't work out, even the ones that you change your mind about, have taught you something. I think in your 20s, you live many, many lives, or at least you should. And changing your mind, being able to interpret what you want in a specific moment, even if that's different from what you wanted before, is a really, really important part of that. And it means that when you get to your 30s or your 40s and you're ready to choose,
步，直到你做出你在开始时决定的那道菜。它是一系列实验。甚至那些没有成功的实验，甚至那些你改变了主意的实验，都教给了你一些东西。我认为在你的二十岁，你经历了很多很多次生命，或者至少你应该这样做。而改变主意，能够诠释你在特定时刻想要什么，即使这与你以前想要的不同，也是其中非常、非常重要的一部分。这意味着当你进入三十多岁或四十多岁并准备好做出选择时，
you have as much information as you need to make the right choice. Now, these decisions, they often require action though, or at the very least like some kind of vocalization. And this is where we find it hard to admit, I have changed my mind. I'm not that person anymore, especially if we've already kind of started down the path. We think that just because we've said we are one thing,
你已经拥有了做出正确选择所需的所有信息。然而，这些决策通常需要行动，或者至少需要某种形式的表达。这就是我们觉得很难承认“我改变了主意”的地方。我不再是那个人了，特别是如果我们已经开始走上了某条道路。我们认为，仅仅因为我们说过我们是某种东西，
we must always be that thing. We must always believe in what we once did with conviction. We must always want what we claimed we once wanted. Why do we think that? Why is that? Of course, it's not one reason. It's never one reason. It's a multitude of reasons.
我们就必须永远是那种东西。我们必须永远坚信我们曾经深信不疑的事情。我们必须永远想要我们曾经宣称自己想要的东西。为什么我们会这样想？为什么会这样？当然，原因不止一个。从来都不是一个原因，而是多种原因。
I think we don't always want to admit we've changed our mind because there is a great deal of cultural messaging to do with sticking things out, not quitting, following through, finishing what you're started, being reliable, being trustworthy. The driver behind this is really other people's desire for continuity from us. They want us to be the same person that we were a year ago and a year before that, so that they can understand us.
我想我们并不总是想承认自己改变了主意，因为存在着大量关于坚持到底、不放弃、贯彻始终、完成你开始的事、变得可靠、值得信赖的文化信息。这背后的推动力实际上是其他人对我们保持连贯性的渴望。他们希望我们和一年前以及再一年前是同一个人，这样他们才能理解我们。
And it's also this idea that, you know, being a hard worker and having follow through gives you some kind of like moral superiority or means that you have a better kind of character. The problem with this framing is that, yes, making promises to other people or making promises to yourself and following through is amazing and should be something that you aspire to do. Not if though you don't actually want to do that thing. We frame this as a failure of willpower that someone just didn't have what it took or just wasn't committed enough, rather than realizing that changing your mind about these things, is actually a really natural developmental process and a really important sign of growth.
这也是这样一种观点，你知道的，作为一个努力工作的人并且有始有终会赋予你某种道德上的优越感，或者意味着你有更好的品格。这种框架的问题在于，是的，向其他人做出承诺或对自己做出承诺并坚持到底是很棒的事情，也应该成为你渴望做的事。然而，前提不是你不真正想做那件事。我们将这视为意志力的失败，认为某人只是没有具备所需的素质，或者只是不够坚定，而不是去意识到，改变你对这些事情的想法，实际上是一个非常自然的发展过程，也是成长的一个非常重要的标志。
But I think that framing is why we feel a lot of shame around, you know, maybe quitting a degree that wasn't right for us, or stepping away from a venture or ending a long-term relationship, whatever it may be that we'd previously committed to because we think it means we don't have a follow-through. We think that it signals that we are a quitter, rather than someone who is actually very, very brave. This cultural conditioning, it is very powerful. Sometimes, you know, I often have this thought where I think, like, I wonder how many people are in loveless marriages or are in careers they don't want or stuck in cities they don't actually like or because they don't want to be, they don't want to be seen as quitting or they don't want to be labeled as unreliable. And how wild is it that
但我认为这种框架正是为什么我们在放弃不适合我们的学位、退出某个项目或结束长期关系时会感到羞耻的原因，无论我们之前承诺过什么，因为我们认为这意味着我们没有贯彻到底。我们认为这标志着我们是个半途而废的人，而不是一个实际上非常、非常勇敢的人。这种文化条件反射，它是非常强大的。有时，你知道的，我经常有这样的想法，我想，不知道有多少人身处没有爱情的婚姻中，或者从事着他们不想要的职业，或者被困在他们实际上并不喜欢的城市里，因为他们不想被视为半途而废，或者他们不想被贴上不可靠的标签。而这难道不疯狂吗：
we have prioritized the opinions of some people that we may not even know or the opinions of people who don't actually have to live our life over our own desires. It's really strange that we do that to ourselves. This kind of brings me to the next big factor. And that is the fear of judgment. mainly the fear of disappointing people as we just said especially people who are close to us for many of us in our 20s let's just say it i think that's our parents and our fear of disappointing our parents isn't one-dimensional it's actually very complex for starters your parents may have
我们竟然将某些我们甚至可能不认识的人的意见，或者那些实际上不用过我们生活的人的意见，置于我们自己的渴望之上。我们对自己做这种事真的很奇怪。这某种程度上把我带到了下一个重大因素。那就是对评判的恐惧。主要是害怕让别人失望，正如我们刚才所说的那样，特别是那些与我们亲近的人。对于我们许多处于二十多岁的人来说，让我们直言不讳吧，我认为那就是我们的父母，而我们害怕让父母失望并不是单一维度的，它实际上非常复杂。首先，你的父母可能
placed a lot of expectation on you that ended up really controlling your life i know this is particularly the experience for firstborns, for eldest daughters, the children of immigrants, for example, the children of high achievers. I'm not an immigrant, so I can't directly speak to that experience, but it's something I get a lot of DMs about. How can I let my parents down? How can I forge my own path? How can I make them value my interests, even if they aren't going to make a whole lot of money when they have sacrificed so much to get me here, so much to get me to this place, to raise me to give me a better life. There was a 2020 study that found that the children of first generation immigrants
对你寄予了厚望，最终真正控制了你的生活。我知道这尤其是长子女、长女、移民子女、高成就者子女的经历。我不是移民，所以我无法直接谈论这种经历，但这是我收到很多私信的内容。我怎么能让父母失望呢？我如何才能开辟自己的道路？我如何才能让他们重视我的兴趣，即使这些兴趣赚不到多少钱，而他们为了把我带到这里、把我抚养成人以给我更好的生活，已经做出了巨大的牺牲。2020年的一项研究发现，第一代移民的孩子
often experience significantly more stress compared to their peers when it comes to meeting their parents' academic expectations. In fact, they often cite it as one of their main forms of academic motivation to please their parents, to live out their parents' dream compared to non-immigrant children who say that often what motivates their study is a sense of personal achievement or some kind of personal goal. They worry a lot less about parental approval, especially again for firstborns. Imagine if you are a firstborn, first generation immigrant. Oh my God, the pressure to not let down your parents must be astounding.
在达到父母的学业期望方面，通常比同龄人经历明显更多的压力。事实上，他们经常将其作为学业动力的主要来源之一，为了取悦父母，为了实现父母的梦想，相比之下，非移民子女说，通常激励他们学习的是一种个人成就感或某种个人目标。他们对父母的赞许的担忧要少得多，特别是对于长子长女来说。想象一下，如果你是长子长女、第一代移民。哦，天哪，不让父母失望的压力一定大得惊人。
And birth order theory, whether you believe it or not, does hypothesize that if you are the firstborn child, the standard for you is higher. The expectations are greater. You are the example. You are being molded to eventually become the guide and the leader for the family. So stepping away from the dream your parents have for you, that's going against decades in some cases of validation and decades of training. You know, if you're 20, 21, 27, whatever it is,
而出生顺序理论，无论你信不信，确实假设如果你是第一个出生的孩子，对你的标准更高。期望更大。你是榜样。你正在被塑造，最终成为家族的向导和领袖。所以，背离父母为你梦想，在某些情况下，就是违背了数十年的认可和数十年的训练。你知道，如果你20岁、21岁、27岁，无论多大，
that's like 20 years that this is the information you have been receiving from those around you. to please them, to impress them, to do what is best according to them. Here's the thing. You have two options here. You can keep up the facade. You can keep up with the expectations. You can keep up with what other people want from you. But that is a choice.
那是大约20年的时间里，你从周围人那里接收到的信息。为了取悦他们，为了打动他们，为了按照他们认为最好的方式去做。问题是这样的。这里你有两个选项。你可以维持表象。你可以保持期望。你可以跟上其他人对你的要求。但那是一个选择。
You do have a choice. I'm going to give you some hard love here. At some stage, you have decided that this is what you're going to. you were going to do. Even if you didn't realize it, you have decided to suppress the deeper individualized version of you. And that might be because it is the right choice based on your priorities. If disappointing your parents or letting them down is more serious to you than choosing your own path, that's okay. You've made that choice. But I just want to remind you that changing your mind is also an option. It will take a whole lot of courage, but on the other side of disappointment is clarity,
你确实有选择。在这里我要给你们一些严厉的爱。在某个阶段，你已经决定了这就是你要做的。即使你没有意识到，你也已经决定压抑内心那个更深层的个性化版本的自己。这可能是因为根据你的优先级，这是正确的选择。如果让你的父母失望或让他们难过，对你来说比选择你自己的路更严重，那也没关系。你做出了那个选择。但我只想提醒你，改变主意也是一个选项。这需要极大的勇气，但在失望的另一端是清晰度，
and is growth. What's the saying? You can't make, you can't make an omelet without breaking a few eggs. You also can't make a life without disappointing a few people who are perhaps expecting too much from you or vicariously living through you. It doesn't make you unkind. In fact, I think not disappointing others would actually mean you're truly being unkind to yourself. It's actually a profound form of honesty and multiple studies, including a very famous one from the University of cargo find that actually being honest about your preferences, being willing to say no or to say I've changed my mind, allows for more genuine happiness in almost, I think the majority of the cases.
是成长。俗话说得好？不打破几个鸡蛋，就做不成煎蛋。不让几个对你期望过高或通过你寄托愿望的人失望，你也无法创造生活。这并不意味着你不善良。事实上，我认为不让别人失望实际上意味着你对真正的自己很不善良。这其实是一种深刻的诚实形式，多项研究（包括卡罗来纳大学非常著名的一项研究）发现，实际上，对你的偏好诚实，愿意说“不”或说“我改变了主意”，几乎在绝大多数情况下都能带来更真切的幸福。
Okay, we're going to take a short break here, but when we return, we're going to talk about sunk cost fallacy. We're also going to talk about why being okay with changing your mind actually means that you could make decisions faster and experience less analysis paralysis. So stick around. We'll be right back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
好了，我们在这里要休息一下，但当我们回来时，我们将讨论沉没成本谬误。我们还将讨论为什么能够接受改变主意实际上意味着你可以更快地做出决定并体验更少的分析瘫痪。所以请留步。稍事休息后我们马上回来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness. experts and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中，关于心理坚韧度、体能以及培养复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，以看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Sent. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
经历一些艰难困苦，你终将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。节目名称中的“2”是英文单词拼写的Two-Percent。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难成长的法则》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖姆斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是，特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person join me Keer games is we have real conversations about healing growth Powerhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们在看记分牌，生活变成了输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的，那代表着两个不同层次的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我的节目《艰难成长的法则》，我们将探讨关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标的真实对话，就在我的新播客《艰难成长的法则》中。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
打开免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《艰难成长的法则》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她说法中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的诉讼之战，以证明真相。埃斯先生，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lepin and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·莱平（Greg Lepin）和迈克尔·马拉尼尼（Michael Maranini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. that Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻。马里科帕县宣布劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义未得到伸张，此事绝不算完。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《受困之爱》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。法则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。说相信你的好闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《闺蜜》中，哦天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？
The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
警察似乎并不关心，所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他将罪有应得。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回顾当年》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。
Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how. we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）作客的节目，他滔滔不绝地谈论着80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备谈论当天的可卡因，只是为了让你们都知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，在这个阶段，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
And for me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So before we talk about why we should all be changing our minds a little bit more and why it's actually really great for psychological well-being and for growth, let's talk about one final reason why we struggle to go back on decisions we previously felt were correct. And that final reason is the sunk cost fallacy. This is a very famous theory. You probably know it by now. But just to summarize, the more we feel we have put into a decision,
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回顾当年》。所以在我们讨论为什么我们都应该稍微多改变一点主意，以及为什么这对心理健康和成长真的很好之前，让我们来谈谈我们难以放弃先前认为是正确的决定的最后一个原因。最后一个原因就是沉没成本谬误。这是一个非常著名的理论。你现在可能已经知道了。但简而言之，我们越觉得自己在某个决定上投入了过多，
we have put into a choice, we have put into a course of action, relationship, job, city, hobby, even identity, the less we feel we can walk away because we believe we will lose all of that time, all of that money, effort, energy that we have invested. That loss, we have a natural loss aversion as humans. We don't want to lose things. We don't want to lose out on things we've previously earned or given to something. It actually causes us to act really, really irrationally. And by irrationally, I mean it causes us to actually act against our self-interest.
我们在一个选择、一门行动方案、一段关系、一份工作、一座城市、一个爱好甚至一种身份上投入了越多，我们就越觉得自己无法抽身，因为我们相信我们会失去所有那些我们已经投入的时间、金钱、努力、能量。这种损失，我们人类有一种天然的损失厌恶。我们不想失去东西。我们不想失去我们之前赚到的或奉献给某事的东西。这实际上导致我们的行为变得非常、非常不理性。我不理性是指它实际上导致我们的行为违背了我们自身的利益。
So let's talk about an experiment that shows this. So this experiment went this way. These participants were, I think I don't know how many there were, it doesn't matter. These participants were given the opportunity to work for $20. They just had to do a series of tasks. And if they did those tasks, they would get the $20. Now, after they had gotten the money, they were then given a 75% chance that they could make $100. But they would have to forfeit their right to that $20.
所以让我们来谈谈一个展示这一点的实验。这个实验是这样的。这些参与者被给予了赚取20美元的机会，我想我不知道有多少人，这并不重要。他们只需要完成一系列任务。如果他们完成了这些任务，他们就会得到20美元。现在，在他们拿到钱之后，他们随后获得了75%的机会去赚取100美元。但他们必须放弃获得那20美元的权利。
the majority of these individuals would not take it. They felt they had put so much time and energy into making that money and they didn't want to give it up even for the chance of winning something much better. That is highly irrational. Now, I know you're probably thinking like, wait, but doesn't that, isn't it just showing that maybe these people don't like gambling? No, because the chances of them winning were 75%. Imagine if I, I told you, you go out and buy a lot of ticket, there's a 75% chance that you would win. Oh my God, I would be doing that because that's the rational choice, right? It was highly irrational in this situation for them to not take that opportunity.
这些个人中的大多数人不会接受。他们觉得他们在赚这笔钱上投入了如此多的时间和精力，即使为了赢得更好东西的机会，他们也不想放弃它。这是高度不理性的。现在，我知道你可能在想，等等，但这难道不是表明这些人不喜欢赌博吗？不，因为他们获胜的机会是75%。想象一下，如果我，我告诉你，你出去买一张彩票，你有75%的机会获胜。天哪，我会这么做的，因为那是理性的选择，对吧？在这情况下，他们不抓住那个机会是高度不理性的。
Because of the sunk cost fallacy, they didn't want to give up what they'd already worked really hard for. And that happens all the time in real life. if you think about my friend and her engagement, you know, I told her this analogy. I was like, you put so much energy into this. You kept up appearances for so long. You really, like, she did truly want it to work. I think that's the sad thing, really.
因为沉没成本谬误，他们不想放弃已经付出巨大努力的东西。这在现实生活中时常发生。如果你想想我的朋友和她的订婚，你知道的，我把这个比喻告诉了她。我说，你在这上面倾注了太多精力。你维持表象维持了那么久。你真的，就像，她确实是真心希望它能成。我想这才是真正令人伤感的地方。
Like, she really wanted it to work. So walking away from it, you just feel like all that time, what was it for? Was it for nothing? In my book, though, I give this analogy. So if you've read my book, I'm sorry, you all know what I'm about to say. But in my book, I give this analogy of this pair of boots that I bought. And at the time, they were like the most expensive pair of boots I had ever bought. You know what?
就像，她是真的很想让它成功。所以当她选择退出时，你就会觉得之前所有的那些时间，究竟是为了什么？难道都是白费吗？不过，我在我的书里举过这样一个比喻。所以如果你读过我的书，我很抱歉，你们都知道我要说什么了。但我在书里举了一个关于我买的一双靴子的例子。在当时，那可以说是我买过的最贵的一双靴子了。你知道吗？
They were the most expensive item of clothing, out of wear, anything that I had ever bought. It was ridiculous. It was like, I think I bought them with my first paycheck when I was working my, like, research job. And I was been waiting to get them for a while. They were so beautiful. they were $300, they were $350, sorry, just to give you, you need to know how much they were for this later part. There were $350 and I wore them to this winery with my friends when I lived in Canberra and they broke. Literally on the first wear the heel like snapped off.
它们是我买过的最贵的衣物、鞋子，或者任何东西。这太荒唐了。就好像，我想那是我用做研究工作时的第一笔薪水买的。而且我等它们已经等了一段时间了。它们太美了。它们售价300美元，不对，是350美元，抱歉，先告诉你们价格，因为接下来的部分你们需要知道这个数字。那是350美元，我穿着它们和朋友们一起去了堪培拉的一家酒庄，然后它们就坏了。简直在第一次穿的时候鞋跟就断了。
Now I'd put $350 into these boots. So I went to a cobbler because they still exist and he fixed it. It cost me $100. Next time I wore them, the other heel broke off, cost me another $100. Then I tore the zipper, cost me like $50. Then they broke again. I kid you not, these shoes were terribly made.
现在我已经在这双靴子上面花 了350美元。所以我去找了一个修鞋匠，因为他们这个职业还存在，他帮我修好了。花了我100美元。下一次我穿它们的时候，另一个鞋跟又断了，又花了我100美元。接着拉链又坏了，大概花了我50美元。然后它们又坏了。我没开玩笑，这鞋做工太差了。
Let's just say that. They were terribly made shoes. And at that point, I had spent more money repairing these shoes when I literally could have just gone and bought a whole new pair. But it's because that investment, that initial investment of $350 and those other continual investments meant that this pair of shoes was no longer worthless to me, even though they literally didn't work. They were worth all that money that I'd put into them. Why was I wearing them? Why did I keep them?
咱们就直说吧。这鞋做工实在太烂了。到了那个时候，我花在修鞋上的钱，实际上已经足够我去直接买一双全新的了。但就是因为那种投入，最初350美元的投入以及后续不断追加的投资，让这双鞋对我来说不再是一文不值，尽管它们实际上根本没法穿了。它们似乎对得起我砸进去的所有那些钱。我当时到底为什么要穿它们？我为什么还要留着它们？
I should have literally just started from zero again and bought another pair of shoes, even if they were less as expensive and less dreamy. Like, because of the sun-cost fallacy. We do that with jobs. We do that with relationships. We do that with career pathways. We do that with, you know, moving to places and realizing actually this isn't the place. that we should live, but we just, you know, we've already told everyone that we're moving
我本该直接从零开始，再买一双鞋的，哪怕它们没那么贵、也没那么让人心动。就像，因为沉没成本谬误。我们在工作中会这样。我们在恋爱中会这样。我们在职业发展道路上会这样。我们在，你知道的，搬到一个地方然后发现其实这里根本不适合我们居住时也会这样，但我们只是，你知道的，我们已经告诉了所有人我们要搬家，
and we've already spent so much money on, like, the removalist. Like, I guess I just have to see it through when really we're not happy. And it causes us to continue to serve an outdated dream. And in the process, forfeit future happiness. If you want to see exactly how susceptible you are to this, to the St.Claught's fallacy, there is a really interesting Harvard study that you can actually go and do, like they have the checklist that gave people a number of scenarios like make a Halloween cape, paint your bedroom, terminate a project and a relationship, and how willing they would be to
而且我们在搬家公司身上已经花了很多钱。所以我想我只能硬着头皮坚持下去，但实际上我们并不开心。这导致我们继续维系着一个过时的梦想。而在这一过程中，我们却剥夺了自己未来的幸福。如果你想看看自己到底有多容易受到这种沉没成本谬误的影响，有一个非常有趣的哈佛研究，你其实可以亲自去测一下，他们有一个检查清单，里面给人们列出了许多场景，比如制作万圣节披风、粉刷卧室、终止一个项目或一段关系，以及他们愿意放弃这个项目的意愿有多高，影响因素是什么。
walk away from that project and what the factors were that would influence that. And their answers determined the susceptibility they had to the sunk cost fallacy in a more real-world scenario. this is a really great way to kind of give yourself some data about yourself learn more about yourself am I susceptible to this and maybe knowing that you are would reveal or help you understand a lot of choices that you'd made in the past and just understand how your brain works for future decisions the thing is again i'm going to sound like a broken record broken record you are meant to change your mind so what's probably stopping you is this whole combination
他们的回答决定了他们在现实生活中的场景下，受沉没成本谬误影响的易感性。这真的是一种极好的方法，能让你获得一些关于自己的数据，更多地了解你自己：我是不是很容易受到这种心理的影响？也许知道这一点会揭示或帮助你理解许多你过去做过的选择，并理解你的大脑是如何运作的，从而指导你未来的决策。关键是，我又要像个复读机一样了——复读机，你注定是要改变主意的。所以，阻碍你的可能正是这样一整组合集：
of fear, irrationality, of social rejection, of disappointing others. So let's kind of flip this narrative and talk about some of the benefits of being the kind of person who can readily admit, I was wrong. I don't want this. I don't believe this. I don't want to be this person anymore. First of all, I think giving ourselves permission to change our mind actually gives us less decision fatigue and a reduced fear of uncertainty. Tell me if I'm wrong. In our 20s, I feel like any time we go to make a decision, there's so much to analyze, so much to think of, so many pros and cons to weigh up that we stagnate.
恐惧、不理性、害怕被社会排斥、害怕让别人失望。所以让我们扭转这种叙事，谈谈成为那种能够爽快承认“我错了”、“我不想要这个”、“我不相信这个”、“我不想再做这样的人”的人的好处。首先，我认为允许自己改变主意，实际上能减少我们的决策疲劳，并降低对不确定性的恐惧。如果我错了，请随时指正我。在我们的20岁，我感觉每次我们要做出决定时，都有太多东西需要分析，太多事情需要思考，有太多的利弊需要权衡，以至于我们停滞不前。
We just don't make a decision at all. That's decision paralysis or analysis paralysis. We have this weird way of thinking. which is that if we think about something more, somehow that's going to mean that the outcome we want is more certain, or we're going to be better able to predict things not going right, that is a complete fallacy, that is a complete lie. We have no idea of telling.
我们根本就做不出任何决定。这就是决策瘫痪或分析瘫痪。我们有一种奇怪的思维方式，
And overthinking and thinking about it too much is just a comfort or reassurance technique that actually means that we stay in the decision phase for much longer than we need to. And it means that when we eventually, do make a choice, we feel such an extreme loyalty to that choice that if it isn't working, we won't walk away. Now, if we decide, because it is a decision that it's okay to change your mind, those decisions no longer feel so final. Uncertainty about these outcomes feels less threatening because we know that if we don't like the outcome, we can always just change it. No longer are we sitting in this like panicked phase of like, this is so important because once I make a
也就是认为如果我们对某件事思考得越多，某种程度上就意味着我们想要的结果更加确定，或者我们能更好地预测事情不会出岔子。这完全是个谬误，是个彻头彻尾的谎言。我们根本无法预知。
choice I'm locked in for life. No, no, no, we can we can make a choice and then make a different choice the week after and the week after that and the week after that. And I know that some people think that that means that, you know, we give up and we start again and we give up and we start again and we don't have follow through. Now, this is about being able to make a decision from a really managed place and almost silence all those other factors that are influencing us and make the decision that's right for us, right? If you think about it, again, not wanting to change your mind doesn't actually come from the fact that the next decision isn't going to be a better decision. If we only thought about things practically and we were only like, oh yeah, probably leaving this
而过度思考和想得太多，只是一种寻求安慰或安心的技术，它实际上只会让我们在决策阶段停留比实际需要长得多的时间。这意味着当我们最终做出选择时，我们会对这个选择产生一种极端盲目的忠诚，以至于如果它行不通，我们也不会选择离开。现在，如果我们决定——因为这本就是一个决定——改变主意是可以接受的，那么这些决定就不会再让人觉得那么不可挽回了。对这些结果的不确定性感觉也没那么具有威胁性了，因为我们知道，如果我们不喜欢这个结果，我们随时都可以改变它。我们再也不用陷入那种恐慌的阶段，觉得“这太重要了，因为一旦我做出了选择，我就被终身锁死了”。不，不，不，我们可以做出一个选择，然后在接下来的一周、再下一周、再下一周做出不同的选择。我知道有些人会认为，这意味着，你知道的，我们放弃然后重新开始，我们放弃然后重新开始，我们没有贯彻到底的执行力。现在，这其实是关于能否从一个真正受控的心态出发做出决定，几乎屏蔽掉所有其他影响我们的因素，做出真正适合我们的决定，对吧？如果你仔细想想，同样地，不想改变主意其实并不是因为下一个决定不会是更好的决定。如果我们只从实用角度去考虑问题，而且只想着，哦，对，离开这段关系可能才是对的。太好了，我要离开这段关系。我们的生活会轻松得多。是所有这些乱七八糟的其他事情在从中作梗。因此，决定忽视这些事情是可以接受的，这将赋予我们更多的自由，让我们在未来做出正确的选择，并在这些选择行不通时做出不同的选择。我不知道刚才说了多少次“选择”。这简直可以当成一个喝酒游戏了。这也意味着我们会变得更具灵活性，对吧？世界上一些最成功的人——人们对此进行过研究，发现他们并不是最聪明的。他们的智商实际上并不是最高的。他们可能没有最多的资源，但他们却是那些能够最快做出反应和采取行动的人。而是什么让他们能够做到这一点？
relationship is the right thing. Great, I'm going to leave this relationship. Our life would be a lot easier. It's all this other stuff that gets in the way. And so deciding that it's okay to ignore those things would give us more freedom to make the right choice in the future and to make different choices when those choices aren't working out. I don't know how many time I just said choices. That's like a drinking game right there. It also means that we would be more flexible, right? Some of the most successful people in the world. And they've done studies on this and found they are not the smartest. They actually don't have the highest IQs. They may not have the most resources, but they are the ones who can respond and act the fastest. And what allows you.
他们不会对别人认为他们应该做什么产生过多的依恋。他们不会纠结，或者说他们不害怕放弃那些行不通的事情。他们不会把太多的自我意识（ego）倾注在失败或错误上，并且他们能非常迅速地从错误的抉择中走出来。这正是我们为自己所期望的。至少这是我为自己所期望的。这也有助于我们挖掘一种名为“可能自我理论”（possible selves theory）的概念。我太喜欢这个理论了，
them to do that, they don't get too attached to what others think they should be doing. They don't get, or they aren't worried about abandoning things that aren't working. They don't put too much of their ego in their failures or their mistakes and they are very quick to move on from wrong choices. That is what we want for ourselves. That's what I want for myself at least. This also helps us tap into something called the possible selves theory. I love this theory.
我现在就向你解释，并给你一种亲身体验它的方法。如果我让你暂停一秒钟，然后我说，想想你是谁。我让你定义你自己以及你是如何看待自己的。你可能会列出你的爱好、你的名字、你的价值观、你的工作、你的恋爱状态，所有这些定义了你当下的东西。现在，“可能自我理论”——这是在20世纪80年代（我记得是80年代或90年代）在斯坦福大学发展起来的——它指出，当我们开始将自己视为不仅仅是现在的自己，而是我们在未来想要成为的人或我们可能的自我时，那些对我们而言可资利用的空间就会
and I'll explain it to you now and I'll give you a way to feel it for yourself. If I asked you to pause for a second and I said, just think about who you are. And I asked you to define yourself and how you see yourself. You would probably list your hobbies, your name, your values, your job, your relationship status, all stuff that defines you right now. Now the possible selves theory, this was developed at Stanford during the 1980s, I think, 80s or 90s, it says that when we start considering ourselves as not just who we are now, but who we want to be in the future or our possible selves, what feels available to us expands
急剧膨胀。当我们开始积极思考该理论所称的“我们所期盼的自我”（hoped for selves）时，情况尤其如此。“我们所期盼的自我”是一个庞大的类别，包含了未来潜在版本的我们，成为那样的我们会让我们感到非常快乐，并且我们非常渴望让这些版本成为现实。基本上，这个理论要求我们将每一个版本的自己都视为同样重要。过去、现在，当然还有未来的那个自己，他们都值得我们的关注，并且他们都指望我们现在就能做出正确的决定。现在做出正确的决定并不意味着你不能改变它。但这要求我们随时准备好
dramatically. This is particularly the case when we start to actively consider what this theory calls our hoped for selves. Our hoped for selves is this big, category of potential future versions of us that we would be really happy to become and that we would really like to bring into existence. Basically, this theory asks us to see every version of us as equally important. The past, the present, and of course the future version of us, they all deserve our attention and they all are relying on us to make the right decision. now. The right decision for right now doesn't mean you can't change it. But asking us to be ready to
做出我们需要的决定。这也帮助我们超越当前对自身处境的情绪、当前害怕让别人失望、害怕被评判或认为自己失败的恐惧，放眼未来，认真思考我们需要做些什么，才能成为我们在未来想要成为的一切。这将会带来多么甜蜜的回报。这简直是一种深刻的、强大的动机力量，它让我们看到“改变主意”或“改变道路”的选择，不再是一种牺牲，而是现在与未来之间一条非常必要且重要的桥梁。它让我们少去思考眼前的痛苦，多去想想未来的回报。你现在就可以为自己这样做。
make the decisions that we need to. And this also helps us rise above our current emotions about our circumstances, our current fears of disappointing others or of being judged or of thinking we failed, and just think way ahead for a second and really just think about what needs to be done for us to become everything we want to be in the future. And how much that, how sweet of a reward that is going to be. This is just like such a profound motivational, motivational force and it allows us to see the choice to change our mind or to change our path, not as a sacrifice, but as a really necessary and important bridge between present and future. And it gets us to think less about the current discomfort and more about the future reward. You can do this for yourself right now.
别去想你此刻的状态。我不在乎你现在是谁。你想成为谁？你想成为的最理想的自己是什么样子的？如果你想不出一个，你可能需要再多动动脑筋。现在，有哪些选择和决定在当下对你不起作用，或者有哪些信念在当下对你不起作用，
I don't think about yourself in this moment. I don't care who you are right now. Who do you want to be? What is the most ideal version of you that you want to exist? And if you can't think of one, you probably need to think a little bit harder. Now, what are the choices and the decisions that aren't working for you right now or the beliefs that aren't working for you right now
正在阻碍你跨越桥梁，从现在的自我通往未来那个可能的、所期盼的自我？我认为，当我们的利害关系发生改变时——当利害关系从“我可能会让别人失望”转变为“我可能会让自己失望，我可能会剥夺自己未来的可能”时——改变主意就会变得容易得多，因为我们意识到这对我们来说有多么严重。最后，改变主意实际上展现了极大的心理力量。
that are stopping you from crossing the bridge between your current self and your future possible hoped for self. I think when we see when the stakes change for us, when the stakes change from I might disappoint people to, I might disappoint myself and I might deny myself my future, it becomes a lot easier to change our mind because we realize how serious this could be for us. Finally, changing your mind actually shows great strength psychologically.
这就是卡罗尔·德韦克（Carol Dweck）的成长型思维理论背后的整个前提。卡罗尔·德韦克，你可能没听过她的名字，但你绝对听过她的理论。她是一位非常著名的斯坦福心理学家，她提出了固定型与成长型思维模式的原则，该原则基本上指出：那些愿意承认自己犯错的人，实际上在心理上比那些无法挑战自我、且抱有“哦，我就是这样的人，我生来如此，我将永远如此”这种信念的人要坚强得多。这种思维方式表现出非常有限的认知灵活性。而这直接与成为一个不那么快乐的人挂钩。为了感到满足，我们实际上必须改变主意。他们已经就此进行了
this is the whole premise behind Carol Dweck's growth mindset theory. Carol Dweck, you may not have heard her name, you have definitely heard about her theories. She is a very famous Stanford psychologist and she developed this idea of the fixed versus growth mindset principle, which basically says people who are willing to admit when they are wrong are actually psychologically stronger than those who cannot challenge themselves and basically have this belief that like, oh, this is just who I am. I was just born this way. I will always be this way. That mindset shows very limited cognitive flexibility. And that is directly linked to being a less happy person. We actually have to change our mind in order to be satisfied. They have done study
一项又一项的研究。有一个非常著名的理论叫做自我决定理论（self-determination theory），它认为，人类要保持健康、快乐和充实，必须满足三个基本的心理需求：自主感、胜任感和归属感。自主感和胜任感，这正是我们在这里关注的重点。我们必须觉得我们能够自己做决定，并且我们的生活是自主掌控的。我们还必须觉得自己在某些方面变得更好了，
after study on this. There is this very famous theory called self-determination theory, and it argues that for a human being to be well and to be happy and to be fulfilled, they have three basic psychological needs need to be met. Autonomy, competence and relatedness. Autonomy and competence, this is what we're focusing on here. We have to feel like we are able to make our own choices and then our life is self-directed. And we also have to feel like we are getting better at something,
我们的能力在扩展，我们在不断进步，在不断改变。因此，剥夺自己改变主意的能力，
that we are expanding our abilities, that we are progressing and that we are changing. So denying yourself the ability to change. your mind is basically denying yourself humanness. It's denying yourself, determination, and happiness. So with all that in mind, I want to give you some final reminders. Some final reminders that will make it easier for you to basically say I was wrong. Firstly, if it is the fear of being judged that is stopping you, I want to remind you that no one cares and that no one is paying attention. Now, this isn't just like a
基本上就是在剥夺你作为一个人的属性。就是在剥夺你的自主决定权和幸福。因此，考虑到所有这些，我想给你一些最后的提醒。一些最后的提醒，能让你更容易地说出“我错了”。首先，如果是因为害怕被评判而阻碍了你，我想提醒你：根本没人会在乎，也没有人在关注你。这不仅是我个人的信念，
personal belief I have. This is like an evidence supported evidence based fact. A 2000 study done at Cornell, I think, I think it was done in like in association with Cornell, basically found that people tend to greatly overestimate how much attention others are actually paying to them and their decisions. You might know this as the spotlight effect. So in this study, Cornell University students were asked to wear embarrassing t-shirts around campus. And they significantly overestimated how many people were going to notice their shirts. What the researchers found was that when they asked the people who were milling around these students on campus, on the green, on the lawn, in the library, very few of them actually noticed
这是一个有证据支持的、基于证据的事实。康奈尔大学在2000年左右做过一项研究，我想，大概是与康奈尔大学联合开展的，该研究基本发现：人们往往大大高估了别人对他们及其决定的关注程度。你可能把这称为“聚光灯效应”。在这项研究中，康奈尔大学的学生被要求穿着尴尬的T恤在校园里走动。而他们大大高估了会有多少人注意到他们的T恤。研究人员发现，当他们询问那些在校园里、草坪上、图书馆里擦肩而过的人时，极少数人注意到了
those t-shirts. Very few of them even remembered walking past. half of these students. This overestimation it stems from us being so focused on our own thoughts and our experiences that we incorrectly project them and project that intense self-awareness onto others and assume that they are also equally aware of us. No one is paying attention to you. No one, some people may, but no one is going to be burdened by your decision to change your mind or to not change your mind more than you are. And for the small majority of people who are
那些T恤。极少数人甚至还记得自己曾与这些学生中的一半人擦肩而过。这种高估源于我们过于专注于自己的想法和经历，以至于我们错误地将它们投射出去，把这种强烈自我意识投射到他人身上，并假设他们也同样对我们时刻保持着觉察。没有人真正在关注你。没有——有些人可能会，但绝对没有人会比你自己更背负着你“改变主意”或“不改变主意”的决定所带来的压力。而对于那一小撮不知为何
somehow really focused in on what you're doing and who are really focused in on your decision to change your opinion or, you know, go back on something you once wanted, you know, for some people, I always say this. For some people, the most interesting thing they can do is criticize others. It's the most interesting thing they're ever going to do in their life. And it's pretty, a pretty sad way of living. What it really is is ego defense or ego protection. It's a shield. If all of their attention is consumed by thoughts about how others are failing or disappointing others or are somehow lying, they never have to turn that focus inwards or around towards themselves. These people, and they are the minority, I will say that, they have a lot of time on their
真的全神贯注于你的所作所为、真的死盯着你“改变意见”或“推翻曾经想要的东西”的少数人，你知道的，对于某些人来说，我总是这么说：对某些人而言，他们能做的最有趣的事情就是批判别人。那是他们一生中做过的最有趣的事了。这是一种相当可悲的生活方式。这实际上不过是自我防御（ego defense）或自我保护。这是一块盾牌。如果他们的全部注意力都被“别人是如何失败的、是如何让别人失望的、或者是如何虚伪的”这些想法所吞噬，他们就永远不必把焦点向内转，去审视他们自己。这些人——我得说这只是少数——他们有大把的闲暇时间。
hands. And that could never be me. And that could never be you. we've got stuff we want to do. Like, I've got stuff I want to achieve. I've got, I've got places I want to see. I've got love I want to share. Like, I don't have time to sit and think about whether, you know, Simon is actually like, what's he doing in his degree? Oh, I heard he's like, I heard he's not doing his degree anymore. And I heard like, wow, what's that choice about? Like, I don't have time to do that. That's your own life. Do what's best for you. I also want to remind you it's never too late to start over. Like literally, ever. My grandma didn't get her degree until she was, like, in her 50s.
而我绝不会成为那样的人。你也不会。我们还有很多想做的事。比如，我有想去实现的成就。我有想去看看的地方。我有想去分享的爱。所以，我没时间坐在那里琢磨，比如说，“西蒙到底在干嘛？他还在读学位吗？哦，我听说他，我听说他不再读那个学位了。我还听说，哇，他这是做的什么决定啊？”之类的事情。我可没空去管那个。过好你自己的生活吧。做对你最有利的事。我还想提醒你，重新开始永远都不会嫌晚。真的，永远不会。我外婆直到50多岁才拿到学位。
And she had a great stint and a great career. My mom, you know, she didn't graduate from university until much later on in her 20s. And even that I think is pretty young. I know we've all seen that post that's like, oh, you know, Vera Wang didn't design her first wedding dress until 50 or Oprah didn't get her first TV show until 37. it's important to have those stories. Do not fall into the trap that you can't change your mind because you don't have enough time to rebuild the life around the next decision you make. There are no rules.
而且她度过了一段精彩的时光，拥有了伟大的职业生涯。我妈妈，你知道的，直到20多岁快结束时才从大学毕业。即便如此，我也觉得那已经相当年轻了。我知道我们都看过那种帖子，上面写着：“哦，你看，王薇薇（Vera Wang）到50岁才设计她的第一件婚纱”或者“奥普拉直到37岁才拥有自己的第一个电视节目”。了解这些故事很重要。千万不要陷入这样一种陷阱：觉得自己不能改变主意，因为你没有足够的时间围绕下一个决定去重建生活。这里没有任何规则。
You have so much more time than you think. Life is very, very long. And I think you would rather die trying to rebuild or build a better life for yourself based on something that actually feels authentic than die having spent more time. in a belief system or an opinion or a life that you actually didn't like, believe in, in joy just for the sake of others. No one else has to live your life for you. No one else is going to face the consequences of not being true to yourself or your future
你拥有的时间比你想象的要多得多。人生非常非常漫长。我想，比起花更多时间活在一个你其实并不喜欢、不相信、也无法从中获得快乐的信仰体系、观点或生活中——仅仅为了迎合他人——你宁愿死在为了基于真实感受去重建或构建更好生活而做出的尝试中。没有人必须替你过你的人生。没有人会比你自己更深切地去承受“未能对自我及未来的可能自我保持忠诚”的后果，也无人会比你更痛苦地品尝“未能做那些他们需要你做的事”所带来的苦涩。别人想怎么评判你就怎么评判你吧。你可以让父母失望。你可以让你周围的人失望。
possible selves and the pain of not doing what they need you to do more than you are. People can judge you or they like. You can disappoint your parents. You can disappoint people around you. maybe you can be seen as unreliable. That pain is never going to be as intense as the pain of looking back and realizing, God, in my one precious life, I didn't do the things I actually wanted because of what? People who are going to be gone anyways?
也许你会被看作是不可靠的人。那种痛苦，永远不会比回首往事时意识到“天哪，在我这仅有一次宝贵的人生中，我竟然因为——为了什么？为了那些无论如何最后都会消失的人？——而没有去做我真正想做的事情”所带来的痛苦更强烈。
Don't let that be you. There is a lot of life to live. There are a lot of mistakes that you will make and choices that you will go back on. One of the most freeing things I think that I've realized recently is like, At some point, the life I currently have isn't going to fit me anymore. And that could be terrifying to realize because I really love my life right now, but I'm also really excited to see what's going to evolve from here and what's going to need to change and how that discomfort is actually pushing me
别让那种事发生在你身上。人生还有大把时光要过。你会犯很多错误，也会推翻许多曾经的选择。我最近意识到的最让人释怀的事情之一就是：在某个时刻，我目前的生活将不再适合我。意识到这一点可能会让人感到害怕，因为我真的很爱我目前的生活，但我也同样非常期待看到从这里将演变出什么、有什么需要改变，以及这种不适感实际上是如何将我推向一个
in a really fruitful, amazing direction. So I hope this episode has served as a reminder for you. If you have made it this far, I would ask that you, leave a little comment down below of something you changed your mind about. Whether it is that you hate eggplant and now you love it, which I don't understand eggplant is disgusting, but whether it's like you change your mind about a food or about a person or about a belief or about what you thought was going to make you happy, let's share them down below because I think seeing other people not be afraid to admit when they were not even wrong, but that something wasn't right for them any longer,
真正富有成效、令人惊叹的方向的。所以，我希望这一集能成为对你的提醒。如果你坚持听到了这里，我请求你在下方留言区留下一个你曾经改变过主意的事情。无论是你以前讨厌茄子现在却爱上了它（虽然我不理解，茄子太恶心了），还是你对某种食物、对某个人、对某种信念、或者对你原以为能让你快乐的事改变了主意，让我们在下方分享出来吧，因为我认为看到其他人不怕承认自己曾经——甚至不是错的，而是某种东西不再适合他们了——
is really empowering. So thank you for listening. I hope this has emboldened you, excited you, inspired you. Make sure as well that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to see a summary of this episode, if you want to see what's going on behind the scenes, if you want to give us an episode suggestion, and that you are following along wherever you are listening right now,
是一件非常赋予人力量的事。所以谢谢你们的收听。我希望这能给你带来勇气、兴奋与启发。请确保在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology Podcast。如果你想看这一集的总结，如果你想看看幕后花絮，如果你想给我们提供一集节目的建议，以及无论你在哪里收听，都要记得点击关注，
whether that is Apple Podcasts, Spotify, the IHot Radio app, title, I don't know, wherever you are, YouTube. Make sure you're following and give us a five-star review. Only if you feel called to do so, it does really help the show grow and reach new people. But as always, thank you again for listening. That's the third time I've said that. Obviously, I'm feeling a lot of gratitude in my heart for you guys right now. But until next time, stay safe.
无论是Apple Podcasts、Spotify、iHeartRadio App、Tidal，我不知道，无论你在哪里，YouTube。请确保关注我们并给我们一个五星好评。当然，仅在你觉得有此意愿时，这确实对节目的成长和触达新听众很有帮助。但一如既往，再次感谢你们的收听。这是我第三次说这句话了。显然，我现在内心对你们充满了感激之情。但直到下一次，保重。
Be kind, be gentle with yourself. Remember, it is okay to change your mind. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more
保持善良，对自己温柔一点。记住，改变主意是没有问题的。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个陌生的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立弹性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家展开对话，还有更多内容
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games.
旨在打破那些主导健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是英文的T-W-O-Percent，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们的主持人、也是你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines）。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的精彩对话。我说的有特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们沉浸在对事物的追求中时，我们会太过于投入到这场追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了那个东西。而我们却仍在追逐它。并且我们不知道什么时候才算“够了”。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？你是个好人，是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，老兄。绝对是的。这是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地、单纯地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《迎难而上》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了他故事中极其明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这就引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你在这份特定的测试中伪造了两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支由互联网侦探组成的“军队”来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg, the Westby and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen,
格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要面对后果了。女士们先生们，
breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
不作死就不会死。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield）。在这新一季的《闺蜜》（The Girlfriends）中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上。警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定将命运掌握在自己手里。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我会成为他的最后一个目标。他一定会得到他应得的下场。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆（Lil' Kim）胸部的那一幕吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回望过去》（Look Back At It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just. because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代“可卡因（Crack）”盛行的节目。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我随时都可以聊当年的可卡因，只是为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆上台面了。谢谢你帮我把那句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled,
在我主持的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个陌生的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立弹性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、
healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T.W.O. % on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
更健康的人。收听《2%》。即T.W.O.Percent，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
她们将命运掌握在自己手中。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他一定会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。
or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back At It》播客中，对于1979年，那对我是个大日子。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
并尝试和我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜欢的作家一起，理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio App、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嗨，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《迎难而上》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
它向世界发出信号：你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你拥有这种能力，你就必须去使用它。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《迎难而上》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你在这份特定的测试中伪造了两处，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Scottsdale Police.
我伪造了一处测试。这需要一支由互联网侦探组成的队伍来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要面对后果了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。